marc l'instant dégorgement sur petites
interventions un gigantesque travail de
fourmi depuis des jours et des jours des
restaurateurs d'art graphique se
relaient au chevet des quelques 700
dessins et estampes du musée qui se sont
retrouvées sous l'eau
chaque lange désormais c'est chez fait
aujourd'hui l'objet d'un inventaire de
restauration futur mais avant il a fallu
agir très vite
notre intervention s'était surtout
d'intervenir en urgence en faisant des
bains de rinçage qui permettent à près
de
de vraiment d'enlever le maximum de boue
pour éviter les tâches directement sur
les ailes sur l'image dans un autre
local à côté ce sont les peintures sur
toile comme sur bois qui font l'objet de
premiers soins
des dizaines et des dizaines d'oeuvres
enlevé pour certaines de leurs châssis
qui sont entre les mains de
professionnels a couru là encore
bénévolement ça fait toujours un
pincement au coeur de voir de voir ses
peintures à biner en même temps je
trouve ça assez surprenant finalement
elles ont elles ont souffert et
maintenant elles ont peu souffert enfin
c'est un peu un mélange et des peintures
qu'on s'attendrait à voir totalement
ruiné finalement qu ont plutôt bien
résistés fin il ya quand même un peu de
surprises aussi pour les peintures qui
était en immersion quasiment complète
quoi pour le musée girodet cette
innovation est une catastrophe
mais elle aurait pu être bien pire sans
le formidable élan de solidarité qui a
suivi
heureusement on a été soutenue par une
armée de restaurateurs et de
conservateurs qui sont venus en renfort
bénévolement pour nous permettre de
sortir les arbres et de leur donner les
premiers traitements pour les préserver
très rapidement plus la restauration
d'une telle quantité d'oeuvres va durer
très longtemps et coûter très très cher
le musée girodet fait appel aux dons